gamespot is back in Las Vegas for CES
2015 and Justin a lot like last year VR
is a big deal we had a lot of companies
sort of jumping into the fray and this
year razor is sort of the big player but
they're doing something a little bit
different yeah razor had several things
that they're showing off here at the
booth they had a new keyboard called the
turret that you play on your couch they
have a solution for streaming games on
your TV but the most interesting thing
is this OS VR which stands for open
source VR but it's kind of a nebulous
concept it's very broad what what is OS
VR exactly right so I mean Razer has a
headset that they will be selling June
15 for $200 this year but what they're
doing is they're making the schematics
for all the the circuit boards all the
the chatzi's and stuff and they're
giving that out to the public so that
the public can iterate on their concepts
they're doing this so that they can sort
of allow the people to drive innovation
in VR faster than maybe a few companies
can cuz everyone's got their own
technology they're keeping it a secret
so Razer is opening it up and sounds
like maybe they wouldn't make a whole
lot of money because they're selling
this headset at cost their game is to
use their sort of know-how when it comes
to controllers and user interfaces down
the road adopts the things that people
do that are successful with OS BR and
then bring their solutions for
controlling to the market yeah it's not
necessarily a competitor to something
like oculus and they've compared it a
lot to Android gaming and making it like
kind of an an open environment for that
stuff to be created yeah it sounds very
like altruistic which in a way it sort
of is but you know at the end of the day
they're doing this so that down the road
they can make money when VR becomes a
bigger thing so it's a very interesting
concept and it's sort of strange to see
open source in the hardware space cuz
that's not something that that's very
typical so is this the biggest gaming
innovation coming out of CES you think I
don't know about the biggest innovation
but it's it's something that's they're
trying to change
the course for what things are the
direction things are going we are
important like so many guys are doing we
are at the show this year I do think
that's what a lot of people want to get
into but will this actually make that
big of a difference and in some ways I
feel that it can like this is making an
opensource will at least get more people
on board with it and make it something
that more people are working on make it
cheaper and get more people with their
hands on it because oculus is
interesting oculus does a really great
job at what that experience is but it's
also very expensive and we don't know
when a retail version is going to come
out yeah well at this point Razer is
basically open the floodgates for anyone
who made them so look at Etsy look at
Craigslist or Ebay for VR headsets made
from your neighbor I guess I don't know
don't buy them it's pretty exciting it's
I'm gonna I'm curious to see what's
gonna come out of this so yeah it's
gonna give off more news coming out of
CES 2015 we've got stuff coming all week